9h du matin top départ la première étape
de ce Versailles traitement festival la
natation dans la fameuse pièce d'eau des
Suisses les athlètes devaient parcourir
une boucle de 750 mètres dans ce cadre
unique en face du château de Versailles
et l'excitation était palpable chez les
500 participants du triathlon du roi
épreuve phare du Versailles triathlon
festival mon premier triathlon donc ce
sera le premier test grandeur nature la
première fois que je suis sur un
événement organisé comme ça même
peut-être la première fois que je vais
enchaîner les trois sports donc j'y vais
en totale découverte je vais pas pour
pour aller chercher un résultat
chronométrique mais juste pour me faire
plaisir voilà le parcours le cadre le
plan de des Suisses est à côté du
château de Versailles c'est pas loin de
chez moi donc ouais c'est un triathlon
qui me plaît pour moi c'est très
important aujourd'hui c'est mon première
triathlon mais la vie ça fait un an que
je m'entraîne pour moi c'est un peu un
challenge de me dire est-ce que je peux
faire trois disciplines enchaînés c'est
pas un format très large pour moi c'est
parfait pour débuter après la natation
les participants ont dû rapidement
enfiler leur tenue de cyclistes pour
s'élancer sur un parcours de 20 km cette
année le dénivelé était plus qu'exigeant
et a mis un rude épreuve les sportifs
[Applaudissements]
enfin la dernière épreuve la course à
pied les athlètes ont dû effectuer deux
tours autour de la pièce d'eau des
Suisses c'est un week-end de fête du
sport enchaîné avec des épreuves pour
tous les âges plusieurs disciplines tous
les niveaux de pratique du complet
débutant jusqu'à l'élite le maître mot
c'est de pouvoir accueillir tout le
monde et le grand vainqueur du triathlon
du roi Axel Hamon il s'entraîne avec le
club Poissy triathlon et la terminer en
une heure une minute et 28 secondes je
m'attendais pas
venir gagner aujourd'hui je j'avais fait
l'année dernière en finissant 16ème avec
un beau plateau là j'avais vu qu'il y
avait pas mal de monde aussi donc
j'étais venu un peu en course de
préparation pour les championnats de
France la semaine prochaine et bah
devenir gagné là c'est c'est plutôt cool
la course s'est jouée dans le sprint
final le deuxième est arrivé avec 10
secondes de retard mais toujours avec le
sourire